this is our real thoughts on Thomas the
Tank Engine ek sorry Maura Wilson oh I
so good she's cool yeah she's very cool
um and it led to I think still my
favorite joke uh and it could have
worked with anyone don't fuck with Mar
Wilson we might make a t-shirt out of
that she was saying that actually after
a half and she's like do you guys do
t-shirts I'm like we used to but you
know we've got oh we do because I went
out yeah now it's like when they will
bring that back because we are doing
shirts again um itgi but we're don't
fuck with morrison shirt uh but anyway
you have this movie Thomas the Tank it
did you grow up with Thomas at all no we
were we were way too old for that I mean
but I think I cut off our cutoff point
didn't start like really really way back
I mean like you did their back like it
just fits in I don't ever remember
watching it in the 80s like I have new
memory cuz I'm nervous Tony it's like
the toys have been around since like I
can remember memory okay maybe the
hallways but I can't remember they had a
show I only started remembering the show
somewhere in the 90s yeah that's why I
remember like I saw it on TV the last
thing I remember watching was Reading
Rainbow
um what PBS yeah mr. Wray mr. Rogers
neighborhood Sesame yeah so Thomas that
you didn't watch Barney yes no well
that's the thing that was the cutoff
point by the time barny the dinosaur
came out I was old and it was popular
yeah I was OD uh yeah I was twelve maybe
already like so I feel like one of you
Barney's be convinced I'm like any watch
Barney oh yeah what was you gonna say to
it um but so but everyone's asking for
this movie mostly cuz unlike something
like Barney's speak adventure where it's
like okay this is for two-year-olds
we're just gonna teach you ABC's we're
just gonna do on the big screen whatever
uh this one got kind of a big cast they
have like Alec Baldwin in it area
bargaining really really doing
god-knows-what
Jerry Patrick um shit who's the guy that
took it way too seriously you have one
Peter Peter Fonda yeah you have one
obviously not taking it seriously Alec
Baldwin once I get way too fucking sick
slang of course the great Marvel yeah
was just like I mean like I don't know I
mean cuz like I said I mean I guess I
could call up and ask here but it's like
she looks like she's at the stage where
she's like you know I like I'm gonna do
this don't get me wrong I agree doing
and getting a nice trip and everything
but uh I think I'll wrap it up on the
acting thing buddy that doesn't kind of
look like this it doesn't look like
she's half-ass well yeah but she's like
you know Thomas things I don't like she
was no you know it is it felt like she
was lost uh like literally like I I mean
that's the the funny thing about it like
looking at this case I'm like what a way
to waste a good child actress like I
realized she's not exactly a child hater
so now it's but it's like we're gonna
cast mara Wilson and Thomas the Tank tit
y-you could have gotten any kid you
don't need Mara Wilson for that I'm sure
anyone would be grateful to have mara
Wilson but it's not something like well
this film it's like Barney's great
adventure was not going to succeed or
fail based on like Haley Joel Osment
yeah or it's like who cares are you
Peter Fonda I mean that's like one of
the great big actors and get Marv Wilson
and they completely waste her like I
just waste everybody yeah I just felt
like I just felt like there was no
reason for any of these people to be
cast you could have gotten complete
unknowns and it wouldn't have made any
what would have made a little bit of a
difference which is Morrow it give us
last jokes yeah I will say this but the
funny thing is it's Thomas the Tank
Engine works as this great experiment in
the three different modes of acting in a
shit film that's sure that's varied you
can either take it super seriously which
is what Peter Fonda does I think he
thinks he's on Golden Pond ders and like
he's he's acting his ass off as if he's
in a serious drama you can Nicolas Cage
it and go batshit crazy which is what
Alec Baldwin did or you can just kind of
be lost and be like lying what like
director what do you want me to do okay
I guess I'll just read the line like yes
I think what what more Wilson's from
yeah so I like that that
middle-of-the-road or whatever just I'm
trying I just don't know what you want
what Thomas the Tank Engine to man
that's
I felt like I felt like her in
particular out of the three she just had
no idea what the direction was even
supposed to be like what what am i doing
like and I I can't imagine this was a
brilliantly directed film like oh no
we're gonna like it just feels like just
here's a kid's film and oh I'll just do
this and so is up to them I guess to
kind of make up their performances and
you know she's younger Alec Baldwin's at
a point in his career where I think he'd
maybe just assume nobody was ever gonna
see this so he's like I'll go insane and
Peter Fonda I guess consummate theater
fuckin Fonda I'm gonna be an aging
professional I'm going to make this the
greatest movie about a toy train you'll
ever see god damn it to a point where
it's just so funny every time it comes
back to every time it comes back to are
honestly uh you know tomorrow sights
like this is somewhere in the middle but
with both Alec Baldwin and especially
Peter Fonda every time it cuts to him
you just immediately start laughing
because you know they're just gonna give
the exact same thing they've been giving
throughout the whole film it's like one
note but such a hilarious note there's a
time in Baldwin's crew with that was pre
30 rock wasn't it oh yeah yeah so this
was at a time in his career when he
really was falling off the radar like
off the grid like so yeah as I said I'm
not sure he thought anyone was ever
gonna see this as like whatever like I
it's such a crazy performance I almost
like want to imagine him like snorting
lines of coke off like coops hammer on
us the Tank Engine all right circle um
make sure it is available you can't get
better um but uh and Peter Fonda is
settle down take this series I'll say
that I remember being very colorful uh
you know I'll give it felt like it was
very bright very colorful and it'd be
great to show the two-year-olds cuz it's
like Teletubbies here's some colors yeah
look patron smiles yeah and I ever went
on his review going on and on about just
how amazingly distracting it is at the
mouths don't talk and I know they don't
talk on the show you can't afford it I
got no how could you not afford it all
you had to do is pull over Mon there go
boo boo bit Matt that's it
and
- evil - the movie you couldn't make
that up really fucking garfield made
that upgrade - cool nationally in
Putin's Christmas vacation do you really
think it matters a taste it's just it
adds to the creep value they are just so
don't be air that did yeah cuz that
would have saved the movie it we've got
it's creepy actually makes the movie a
little more interesting to watch as a
drug trip I guess but that's a little
kid I just feel like they're not talking
man they're all psychic they're all
possessed they're all fucking something
honestly in retrospect thinking about
the movie I think mara Wilson looking
lost is the best thing to happen to the
film cuz she may be the only thing
that's grounding in that picture yeah
that is because he's because peer bond
is too much in that you know a less
harsh reality connected balancing off
the walls like fucking flubber likes it
and then there's just mara Wilson stuck
in the middle like she's the one trying
and credibility like shit net that was
your credible bridge between the two
actors
I swear everyone Swan that movie she has
this look on her face like what the fuck
am i watching this it's just so bizarre
um but yeah in terms of like I can't
remember those story I just never jumped
around a lot and it was just somebody in
the Tank Engine what do you saw there
something in the story trains and a
crazy-ass conductor yeah says something
like that um and it did make for it was
just so odd though and the tone changing
so much I mean it did make it I actually
do kind of have fond memories of doing
this review um I remember just like it
was so strange but it was also there is
a part of me that wants to be a little
bit more lenient when something is
bright and colorful because at the very
least it's not it's giving me something
visually pleasing instead of just gray
or rain or dark like Godzilla or
something like here's the thing though I
know Care Bears was bright and colorful
and wasn't much better functioning
children's movie like even within we're
gonna come back to that a lot don't we
say that a lot like you know Care Bears
is better than this I hear example I
think I'm trying to think of the one
example of a film that is really made
for five-year-olds I mean you're not
going much higher than the age of five
on Care Bears and I'm like really made
for fibres but still functions as a
story just enough yeah like it's not a
great movie but is it
it's either good I use their Tiger
there's a cheap corporate shill movie
like it did it alright so I mean even on
the setting the bar so low for a
cheap-ass kid's film like you can still
pull off something that's bright and
colorful but as a parent you could at
least get through it I this movie just I
could beat my head against the wall I'm
just like make it stop
well something that Romare she Tamar
wasn't said to is that she was talking
about sorry tell so much about Myra but
but it does tie back into this that she
was saying she was in a lot of kids
films because I think both she and her
parents thought that there need to be
more kids films and the right back then
it was very true and other girls were
just suggesting I was the Dark Age of
films it was just they were if movies
back then somebody's respecting us
knocked around hit kids films were just
expected dead on arrival they were just
dead yeah and you could see it she's
trying to like hey well this sounds kind
of imaginative you know she's like
here's a fairy godmother trying to you
know get things together into and it
sucked well here's Thomas the Tank
Engine popular show well may it be good
for looking it sucked and they
intentionally tried the intentions were
good but it's just like you can have an
actor actress with the best intentions
but if nobody else knows what they're
doing that's or maybe that's kind of
what it felt like like maybe people did
try but they had no idea how either then
no idea how or like studio or something
kept chiming and say no no we have to
stick to this crappy lazy formula or we
have to just get this out fast I don't
just get it out really quick grab
somebody grab whatever I'm not I feel
like I somebody clearly a lot she was in
people somewhere did not I feel bad for
Mara Wilson that film too because she
was in the right mind so that the wrong
time can you imagine now wanting to do
that now now there's so many options she
could have done and it's it's sad like
that she must have but she's in New York
now did she's doing play right stuff and
so and we're not worried about her it's
just a shame that that was her mindset
and like it's just great idea wrong time
well ya know and she went ahead she's
been that age like ten years later she
could have had her pick of white good
kids film yeah well now I will say
Muslim Arianna
now um thank you she could be a voice
actor say you know you never know
um but yeah there's just a time when
it's just aside from Pixar uh kids films
were just expected to be awful he didn't
rival did Disney was terrible three more
extreme works was cranking out what out
of every three films was decent like but
they had a button there was that you
know I thought Prince of Egypt was great
and I felt like they hit a slump for a
long time yeah only recently and even
then they're hitting this but you know
Kung Fu Panda is really good and How to
Train Your Dragon but it yeah so i don't
know i yeah i'm it sucks it's nice it's
it's nice knowing now that's like and
you know prone con people see them as
money
I think these family fells and it makes
sense bicha I just a whole Toria on this
on a kid shows um you know they see the
money now and they see if they make
these really good so that adults want
see them later and they're cashing in on
the nostalgia like hey not only do I
want to see this because I remember it
but because it's good you're doubling
your audience so it makes sense to make
them good uh and Pixar had a big change
in that as well you know just saying hey
we can you know make jokes and write
these so that they're hitting the adults
just as much as the kids and you can
enjoy it at any age you know it's okay
and I like that it's profitable and this
just came out at age where it just it
wasn't uh and then they weren't trying
it this is like the with the Ogilvie's
of its day or the thing with its cool I
don't know I know what you're talking
about whatever the biggest bomb or
whatever in history or the something
good squeal ooh geez Boo Boo's I round
up the kids movie that came out just not
too long ago yeah well I don't know a
while ago now something like five or six
years was it yeah no as a while we're
gonna know right um but uh yes I wasn't
I don't like I don't hate this film it's
one of those were it's like Jason man
might not find it if yeah it's kind of
entertaining Lee bad in its goofy way
and stuff and just like I said all the
actors are clearly just in three
separate movies and there's some where
they like her idea there
Johnson don't work on me that may have
actually contributed to the reason why
there are three completely different
performances
maybe it's like three directors who
knows yeah it might be Mike Marra looks
laws Baldwin's I don't know what the
hell he's doing and then Peter found is
like I thought this is gonna be sick
I thought there's gonna be Holocaust
right yeah so um yeah I can't think it
too much else to say about it just that
you know if you grew up with the show I
mean great uh I'm sure you were the
intended age and I'm sure it's fine I've
never seen the show either maybe it's a
better I don't know but I do know this
is not one of those where I got a lot of
recommendations for it and then when I
did people are like you're shut the fuck
up I want all this attention um my my
feeling left it's so much why did you
recommend Lee review yeah so it's it I
don't know anything with a big fan base
where they love it or hate it is gonna
be executive dan so you're gonna be
intense over intense hey but there's
also intense number cuz a lot of people
watch me a lot of people live this way
you don't want if they did a mr. Rogers
movie there was this bad I would have no
Brown reviewing it mmm yeah I love yeah
we love mister really thinks the show
was good and I love mr. Rogers too as a
show but if the movie was this bizarre
and just didn't really do anything
involved in a justice or didn't aim any
higher than the show then yeah I would
have but somehow I see mr. Rogers trying
to put out a better quality I mean a we
love Garfield I mean we were like dark
oh yeah junkies when we were again this
that movie was awful we stand like all
the collections all the tears you watch
Garvey and frankly we long yeah and it's
so yeah I mean just because we love
something as a kid or growing up or
whatever whether or not hole doesn't
mean that the movie version can't suck
yeah um so but on the on the bright side
it gave us a great running joke with
Marvel's
yeah uh I still think that's like I I
just can't think of one that's funny
you're like we lose like that was one of
those before like whoops moments that
turned out really good like cuz she
emailed you like cuz someone went up
well no no she that the way it works it
just a somebody I invite somebody turned
her to the video well I guess a lot of
people I guess right after the town
Tank Engine lot of people were like who
he hates you he tears yeah boy to do
that with us and boof to like can you
believe with these guys and saying it's
like okay yeah um but and she saw it
didn't know it was a character was just
like you know it some imagine I think
she was saying like she just got out of
like something else that was like some
sort of slander in a British newspaper
article or something like them and she
sees this as well as poisonous asshole
who is you know blah and then like
immediately after like I I contact her
and just say hey you know just know it's
it's a character he's actually meant to
be kind of a loser and then not to take
you seriously I mean amazingly Roy is
just like you and I didn't know I you
don't know the context then yeah that
could happen let's be fair like if you
don't realize it's a character because I
mean your idea of being a character is
just to put on a silly hat in a tie um
then yeah you would be looking at this
like wow what a dick yeah you know but
then when yeah I mean Amelie got baked
just like dude I'm so sorry I I see when
people said it was a character I thought
they meant like oh what a character type
of thing so I mean and we just talked to
merit just like hey would you be uh down
for a cameo or something I mean this is
bad when I don't even make an appearance
on screen like since her last movie or a
play I don't know she was all I remember
seeing her in was those like BuzzFeed
lists of you'll never believe what this
child actor actress is doing now and
like her what do they look like now and
like that that's all I had seen her even
though I didn't see them back then
because I don't even think she had like
the you know the pictures out or
anything like that so to suddenly out of
nowhere just see her you know I mean
looking great it I need just grew up
great and just acting just as well as
she did uh you know it's just how can
you top that and how can you top to all
that such a good sense of humor and just
I mean when she did that evil laugh I
mean just that's there's like she bailed
on the evil laugh ha ha ha ha ha ha ha
ha ha I'm going eyes and it's that was
the most fun I probably had editing Nick
Amaro Wilson yeah like special effect
big cuz like we just left it there and
I'm like dunk I think I can make her
eyes glow like the devil and then I can
turn the screen red and and
I remember I was like but maybe we
should ask her first yeah and then she
was like totally to it that BiH she was
all game so she was really gracious to
let us do that and I think she had a lot
of fun with him then that ended up I
think it's a bold Leafly we put don't
fuck with mara Wilson as a pet yeah
that's right so wait we gotta work on a
shirt for that oh yeah go ahead uh but
uh yeah that's our uh that's our
thoughts on Thomas the Tank Engine uh
didn't know much about the show um
obviously you really know much it's one
of those surreal moments to like at
least for me I don't know about you but
if you had told me when I was watching
mrs. Doubtfire gonna work with this
person in 1994 oh yeah at some point
she's gonna grow up and then you're
gonna like do a quick video with this
version she's gonna cameo for you I
would've been like what or or Rufio or
piano brain it's amazing the hell are
you talking this is like you're crazy
no it's it's really amazing and I mean
what we praise and glorify the fuck out
of her but we are still very very
thankful for not killing us you know
it's the way it was handled it is one of
those thing I mean it's just another one
of those situations where it shows what
a good sense of humor and a good outlook
can get and what it can lead to so yeah
I I have fun memories of this review and
I enjoyed it yeah it was definitely fun
to do um so sparkle Sparkle Sparkle
fuck yeah sparkle Sparkle Sparkle